Thanksgiving is easily one of the
biggest holidays of the year right but
there are no memorable Thanksgiving
characters for kids oh yeah
look every other holiday has it there's
no Santa Claus there's no Easter Bunny
there's nothing for Thanksgiving not
really no it's it's a crime it's
terrible well that's about to change
I'd like to introduce our brand new
Thanksgiving character he spreads joy
and make sure every Thanksgiving meal is
complete please welcome stuffins the
elephant on this Thanksgiving gay stuff
has made a tasty dish that is warm and
soft and squishy so open wide when you
hear stuff in say who comes the stuffing
his name is stuffing
I'm cream people filled with something
static competition well confused and
nature has refused to provide a simple
explanation of this elephants condition
where a starchy haughty mission shoots
rubbish trumpets tuppence makes this
tasty exclamation that's that's great
that's that's fine that's fine thank you
happy Thanksgiving you know it it really
doesn't look like stuffing
[Music]
something seated but please only because
the something made inside an elephant
[Applause]
ooh you're welcome kid my stuffings the
elephant wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]